[موسيقى]
الثال عشر من يوليو تموز من العام
2022 الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن في اول
زياره رئاسيه له الى اسرائيل ها هو يا اير
لابيد سعيد بمنصبه الجديد رئيسا للحكومه
الاسرائيليه بايدن لم يزل يتحرك في النصف
الاول من فترته الرئاسيه حيث الوعود
الانتخابيه قيض النظر المختبر الوفاء بها
يتودد بايدن الاسرائيليين مزهو بصهيون ته
منطويا على امل استكمال اختراقات سلفه
ترامب في المنطقه العربيه التي ادت الى
تطبيع دولتين خليجيتين مع اسرائيل فضلا عن
اخرين يتحينون السوانح للدخول في اتفاقات
ابراهام حيث كل شيء سيكون في اتم ما تريده
اسرائيل سلام اعم استقرار اكثر تواصل اكبر
هذا امر جد مهم ولعلي اضيف انه مهم كذلك
لكل شعوب المنطقه ولهذا السبب سنناقش دعمي
المتصل لحل الدولتين رغم اني لا ارى ذلك
ممكنا في المدى
القريب عباره بايدن ترقى الى ان تكون
اسدال للستار على مسار عمليه
السلام العمليه التي انتهت بالسلطه
الفلسطينيه
هلا موهما بوجود سلطه هي في واقع الامر لا
سلطه ولا سياده لها على شيء كان الفلسطيني
في غزه او في الضفه الغربيه يمد بصره فلا
يرى الا افقا لا وعد فيه ولا حياه الا تلك
التي ترسمها قوه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تقتل وقت تشاء وتعتقل من تشاء
وتهدم البيوت لا يسائلها في الدنيا احد او
تصادر الارض فتصاب
[تصفيق]
حلوم ثم جاء
الطوفان تقول حماس انه جاء ليعيد تعريف كل
شيء تعريف الحرب كيف تكون تعريف معنى حرب
التحرير والاستقلال تعريف الكرامه تعريف
الحلم الفلسطيني وتعريف ماذا يعني ان
تقاوم وماذا يعني ان تقاتل من اجل استرداد
حقوقك المنهوبه في الارض وفي الحياه
الكريمه هنا الرئيس بعد مره اخرى يعود بعد
طوفان الاقصى وهو مثل
الاسرائيليين لا يصدق ما جرى انها
الصدمه ليست صدمه اليوم الاول بل الصدمه
من صمود غزه في وجه القوه الاسرائيليه
التي لا تقهر في المنطقه بل من ايقاع
الخسائر بجنودها وعتادها الحربي على نحو
لم تره اسرائيل في حروبها السابقه
جميعا الله الله اكبر ما يمكن وصفه بالحرب
الكبرى في غزه اعادت للقضيه الفلسطينيه
مشروعيتها التي تراجعت تحت وطاه الهزائم
والانكسارات ووهم الانتصارات الصغيره
يشيعها توقيع اتفاقات والتزامات هنا وهناك
ثم لا يكون لها من اثر في اليوم التالي
دفعت الحرب الكبرى في غزه واشنطن وعواصم
غربيه للتفكير في اعاده طرح حل الدولتين
وهي التي كانت قد اكتفت بالترويج اللفظي
له الان عليها ان تعيد التفكير في العمل
وخطته لجعل هذا الحل ممكنا ولو كان ذلك
على حساب تفصيل دوله للفلسطينيين بمواصفات
منقوصه علها تقبلها اسرائيل لتحافظ على
امنها واحيت الحرب الكبرى موضوع اقامه
الدوله الفلسطينيه باعتبارها شرطا لازما
للسلام في المنطقه اتجاه يقوى ويتصاعد
داخل المجتمع الدولي الذي يتجاوز حتى الان
الطرف الفاعل على الارض والذي غير
المعادله ولا يزال وهو المقاومه في غزه
وهذا ربما دفع كثيرين في امريكا وفي
اوروبا لمراجعه مواقفهم تحت شروط الواقع
الجديد فالحديث حول حل الدولتين سيكون
جمله ناقصه حتى تكتمل بكيف
[موسيقى]
ومتى واكثر من حملتهم الحرب على كره منهم
الى مراجعه القضيه الفلسطينيه وحق الشعب
الفلسطين في دولته هم الاسرائيليون انفسهم
فبعد طوفان الاقصى عم شعور داخل اسرائيل
بان فكره بقائها امنه هي فكره واهمه وهناك
من ذهب الى ان الحرب قد كشفت بالفعل عن
ازمه وجوديه لدوله اسرائيل وان واقعا
جديدا قد فرض شروطه وتجاهله سيكون محض عم
وانكار للواقع ومع ذلك فان نتنياهو انصاره
في الحكومه وخارجها يرفضون فكره الدوله
الفلسطينيه اصلا ولا يرون بديلا عن سلطه
امنيه اسرائيليه تتحكم في غزه غزه التي لم
تقل مقاومتها بعد كلمتها في اطروحات
الدوله الفلسطينيه التي لم تستشر فيها ولا
يمكن تجاوزها بعد اليوم في
اقامتها الحرب الكبرى التي تخوضها
المقاومه في غزه وفي مقدمتها حماس قدست
مسيره المشروع الوطني الفلسطيني بما قدمه
الشعب من تضحيات بعشرات الالاف من الشهداء
والمصابين
والمفقودين وهو ما رفع سقف التطلعات
الفلسطينيه عاليه كل الظروف اللي بنعيشها
مش حنطلع من بلدنا لان هذه بلدنا عشنا
فيها انولدنا فيها وعشنا فيها وهنموت فيها
اما محيط حماس العربي الذي يتابع من بعيد
الا من اليمن وجنوب لبنان فهو معني بنتائج
هذه الحرب انخرط فيها او تجافى عنها فلا
تطبيع بعد اليوم تؤمن عواقبه ولا شرق اوسط
كبيرا او صغيرا لا تكون الدوله الفلسطينيه
في قلب منظومته ولا استقرار ولا ازدهار
والجوع يعصر الفلسطينيين رجالا ونساء
واطفال في غزه في
مسيرتهم المخضب بالدم لنيل استقلالهم ربما
تواتي الفرصه الان المجموعه العربيه
والاسلاميه ان تستدرك ما فات عليها وذلك
بتبنيها موقفا ضاغطا بشكل جماعي مناصرا
ليس بالضروره لحماس ولكن لحق الشعب
الفلسطيني كله في نيل حقوقه وفي مقدمتها
دولته هل سيجرب ما جربت حماس من الجراه
فالتاريخ عاده لا يمنح
صحائفه للايدي
الواهنه